[Música]
a prisão em questão também de um lado os
influenciou nada se consegue saber quem
estou a falar pois é estou a falar das
nossas crianças
além das crianças vivem em pensionatos
impressionados com os filmes ainda
muitos preta são a opção escolar sem as
pressões sociais e estes são fatores que
geraram desequilíbrio e comprometem o
crescimento harmonioso dos diferentes
contagens familiar continua
atualmente as crianças brasileiras
conecta pensado dos nove vagas com falta
de respeito
então vamos mudar esta visão atual e
pudéssemos ter crianças mais confiantes
mais seguras puder ser disputado em
pimenta sua cria final e imaginação
porque cada vez mais deste equilíbrio
que a gestante as nossas crianças
sinalizadas são seus estilos das
provisões ela novas salas falta de um
sistema de ensino que obrigaria a rachar
fechada uma sala em tinta para acertar
muitas vezes
estou contracenar com vitinho sinais de
que pensa
depois veio a questão devia ser
imperativa não muitas vezes não é essa
não é imperativa a criança precisa se
limitar a criança precisa de tempo
sempre para aguentar um tempo para curar
tempo para receber atenção contato
físico com carinho e um abraço por
exemplo tempo para sem conhecer o tempo
para ser criança
enquanto nós aqui na em tempo está em
nosso dia pra passar o nosso filho
agora fez o que tem lá sentimos isso
sigo novos lá
ae
até na hora
não obrigado
pode ser na área mas é difícil eu
conheço um nota
apesar do aumento não vencemos o mesmo
quintãns é difícil lançar o contato
físico
o aumento em moda e é isso que estamos a
passar com as nossas crianças
falta sensibilidade de um tom da falta
de empatia e principalmente falta de
tempo
então minha proposta é isso mesmo
dá tempo a criança é criança como
individual com as suas próprias
capacidades propriedades indigência e
conhecer o seu entre o seu ser interno
três gols e vamos apresentar alguns
fundamentos que ajudaram o equivalente
já estão a ajudar a proporcionar à
criança e se o tempo para que é o seu
novo inquilino é incrível mesmo dentro
do estilo de vida tão interessantes em
que vivemos com 9 a infantil e apoiar a
família do tempo para se adaptarem a uma
nova realidade
o sentido da mensagem
para o bebê mas mais baratas técnicas
mensagem é passar a importância do tom
o top entre pequim e tóquio
webber é inútil é criança e os pais
também entoou o primeiro é primeira
linguagem dos pais também é 100 com a
criança
afinal o tato tem mais sentido ainda a
última terra eo último a deixar os réus
a importância do dó é um vínculo
emocional
andrósio o bebê está já também descer do
carro lançado timoni espera com isso
estimular irá mais consciência do seu
próprio corpo vai aprender a relaxar a
inter g em cima tudo a ser respeitar e
respeitar o toque quanto tempo
precisamos nós para ganhar como sempre
sair pelo equilíbrio emocional da
criança nem ter envolvimento em contrato
vai no yoga uma ferramenta que pudesse
estarão na mentalidade quesito dessa
estada de 90 do potencial que cada
criança
respeitando o tempo espaço então yoga
para crianças têm mesmo básico e outros
produtos
quero trabalhar por estas histórias
músicas jogos e relaxamentos
visualizações e através de através
destas técnicas são ultimados os
princípios da não violência de ajudar e
não tenha em com as posturas físicas as
posturas de yoga paulo o corpo da
criança para o desenvolvimento da
inteligência e das insight
nestas aulas a criança tem esse tempo
para brincar e dançar pra imaginar para
se conhecer principalmente conhecer o
seu ser interno verdade o seu eu como
estas técnicas já criaram sabendo de
cícero olhar pra desse menino criar um
mar calmo interna registrados fina para
todas as vertentes da sua vida em todas
as suas comunidades
uma das filhas como reta e flexibilidade
mas ao longo da vida não tem dados é
dominados
ela espera então yoga para crianças vai
ver na pista mesmo as autoridades nascem
com a doença
temos um exemplo dos praianos são
exercícios dos piratas a criação do
espírito
esta vai ver lá e viver as suas funções
de forma muito mais com sheila paz ao
mesmo tempo dão corpo a uma das
ferramentas costumam utilizados aulas
para trabalhar a respiração espera de
obra não é muito conhecida pelas
crianças
riga favor quando eu a viola produzir
nessa esfera
vamos com teixeira a nossa barriga d
água quando o xá a respirar sem
inspiração e com dores
estamos a treinar assim a respiração
nasal ea descrição é nominal que é
inspiração nas crianças respirar
assim a unidade na rua com essas
unidades e que postura corporal direita
filho há nada o que vai deixar a 1
mãe é mãe
emocional e aprendendo a utilizar essas
ferramentas se há naturalmente mais
confiança
o pensamento física avaliação física
temos uma reação metal e é isso que nós
trabalhamos explicar
a criança e nesse natal luz sobre as
opções show levar um pouco de calma com
a analogia ao corpo do bebê essa que
quando está animada e limitada nervosa
todas as suas missões estão molhados
como aqui no porta-malas dirigir o olhar
pra ver se identificar condições está
sentindo valas organizar dentro do seu
corpo só para todas as missões que
tiverem organizadas calmas arrumadas
pronta prazo podemos ver o káká através
do movimento científica yoga são para as
mães o ar aumenta de forma generalizada
pois a criança não e concentração
envolvem melhor capacidade de
relaxamento muito motivo para realizar
estudos mais eficaz
tudo isso faz com que a criança grande
aumenta aumenta
sua autoestima e autoconfiança uma vez
que cria essa estátua de ganhar
o foco foi relegado à força
a criança que quer que eu faça tudo
aquilo que se propõe ainda mais coragem
para viver sem água também é mais
autoconhecimento a criança começa um ser
individual o único suas emissões às suas
reações no centro do prato é competitiva
acho que lá fazer um bom espírito de
grupo e compensar o faz com que a
criança está enviado - mais à vontade
para interagir então tem com essas 12 em
consideração a pergunta impõe porque as
escolas ainda não integraram os seus
currículos
este refinados que isso aconteça eu
comprei pai das crianças são convidadas
de honra desta tática
afinal essa criança é isso mesmo é viver
o espírito fantástico elas márcia
totalmente diferente
então porque não tinham lá pra cima da
energies não é então para que eles
também possam nos prestigiar só entre os
benefícios desta prática
eu quero partilhar convosco uma técnica
de relaxamento e meditação um vizinho
tem cessado
acho que max era imaginação ao mesmo
tempo vivendo muito presente
o aqui eo agora em relaxar e se estava a
fazer dotes saltos método eu peço que se
sentem com fundamento nas escadarias da
forma mais confortável na festa eu estou
te inspirar profunda e trazer a nossa
consciência é estudar apenas dez números
vão esquecer tudo o que inclui que visto
lá fora sentir cada parte do nosso corpo
em antonina
e olha vamos imaginar que o nosso corpo
só faço mim só que desta vez mais espaço
aos pretos este físico só mais um que
vai utilizar uma ninfa lá acima
olhares para baixo e 20 grande duas
crianças a brincar vai jogar mas corre
foi isso que nos ouvir seus gritos de
felicidade
vamos ouvir os diversos estágios
lentamente o nosso time pat xix mas até
oscilando de sua criança descobriu então
fui a ge ea vida que nos aproximamos
mensagens de ver os seus carros os seus
sorrisos e suas frações aproximados é
das regiões dessas crianças somos nós
cantam um dos presentes nesta sala vai
ju vai junto
foi a lei mas fora voltar eu em também
os engenheiros volta dos 10 na os termos
fé respiramos
[Música]
eu também - o juiz
então vou para ser campeã não é tão bom
assim mato poder de entre a nossa
criança entre o e se pudéssemos fazer
desta sexta são boas preços
diferenciados é nossa realidade
eu digo então fazer desde então eu peço
atenção à nossa realidade porque educar
crianças não pode ser apenas juntos esta
noção os times que informações
vamos então formal da obra e nas nossas
crianças
estes maravilhoso tempo para ser
[Aplausos]
[Música]